entonces repasemos un poquito de todo lo
que hemos aprendido hasta este punto
como cuál es la representación en serie
de mclaren de las funciones por ejemplo
a la x entonces ésta tiene una
representación en serie de mclaren como
una suma infinita de términos como la
que sigue de hecho mencionamos en vídeos
anteriores que no vamos a darle
demostración de hecho abandoné la
búsqueda de la demostración porque no
pude pensar en una prueba que fuera
intuitiva y que no fuera complicado
probablemente después que expliquemos
otras cosas podríamos dar una prueba de
este resultado pero para fines de
aprobar la materia de cálculo para lo
que queremos hacer en este vídeo no lo
necesitamos así que créanme lo que la
serie de mclaren de ea la x como ya
habíamos visto es igual a 1 + x mas x
cuadrada sobre 2 factoriales + x al cubo
entre 3 factorial + x a la 4
4 factorial más x a la 5 entre 5
factorial también sumamos x a las 6
entre 6 factorial esto empieza a ser un
poco tedioso más x a las 7 entre 7
factoriales más x a la 8 entre 8
factorial y así nos seguimos hasta el
infinito verdad muy bien muy bien ahora
si tomamos este todos los términos hasta
el infinito de esta serie a la x
es exactamente esa suma infinita verdad
ahora cuál es la serie de coseno de x
digamos coseno de x como lo vimos en
otros en el vídeo hace dos vídeos era
uno más
más x cuadrada entre 2 factorial
no no perdón este no es un más este era
un menos recuerdan déjenme borrar esto
el signo aquí en realidad es un menos
así que nos queda 1 - x cuadrada entre
dos factores
y ahora nos falta vamos hasta más x a la
4 entre 4 factorial menos x a la seis
sobre seis factorial es más creo que ya
vamos ya van viendo hacia dónde voy
verdad x a la 8 entre 8 factorial y así
nos seguimos también hasta el infinito
el próximo tendría signo menos verdad y
nos estamos tomando las potencias pares
ahora cuál es el desarrollo en serie de
maclaurin para la función seno de x
tenemos seno de x es igual a x menos
menos x al cubo entre 3 factoriales más
más x a la 5 entre 5 factorial menos si
x a la 7 entre 7 factorial y así nos
seguimos en adelante hasta el infinito
también aquí tendríamos un x a la 9
entre 9 factorial y ya conocen el patrón
que vimos en vídeos anteriores paremos
un momento porque esto es algo que de
verdad cree
de verdad creo que si lo entiendes es de
las pocas cosas en la vida que dan unos
escalofríos terribles y quiero que vean
que hay un orden en el universo que los
humanos sólo podemos entrever porque
nuestra mente es limitada pero estamos
en el borde estamos arañando la
superficie del entendimiento del del
orden del universo así que quiero que
vean que cada uno de los desarrollos en
serie de mclaren
si los escribimos como simples
polinomios cada una de ellas parece una
parte del desarrollo de la equis verdad
cuando habla cuando hablo de la de
coseno de x y seno de x solo que hay
cambios en los signos
pongámoslo más claro qué pasaría si yo
definiera la función coseno de x
más seno de x
x ok a que sería igual pues bueno vamos
a tener que sumar todos los términos y
hacemos un desarrollo en serie porque
básicamente de sumar ambas filas por
ejemplo tendríamos 1 más x menos x
cuadrada entre 2 factoriales menos menos
x al cubo entre 3 factorial más más x a
la 4 sobre 4 factorial me sigo con x a
la 5 entre 5 factorial
- x a la 6 sobre 6 factorial menos x a
las siete sobre siete factorial más x a
la 8 entre 8 factorial y así no
seguirían seguiríamos verdad el
siguiente sería menos etcétera hasta el
infinito ahora creo que debe quedar
claro para ustedes y aquí es donde se
pone la piel de gallina porque miren
esto
miren el desarrollo cuál es la
diferencia sólo es un par de signos que
se va
alternando déjenme marcarlos con un
color más vistoso estos dos la
diferencia entre esta serie y esta otra
de acá arriba son estos signos de
negativos que estoy marcando resulta que
esto ya lo había yo visto antes ya lo
había aprendido antes de hecho muchos
matemáticos ya lo sabían desde hace
siglos y les diré algo no hay nadie a
pesar de que pueda ser demostrado no hay
nadie que realmente entienda por qué
pasa esto porque tomando las funciones
trigonométricas que aparecen ya saben
cuando tomamos los cocientes de los
lados de un triángulo rectángulo con la
definición del círculo unitario que
resulta útil para triángulos de todo eso
de la trigonometría así es como sacamos
las funciones seno y cosenos y está en
relación con el círculo y toda esa onda
así que cuando sumamos estas dos
funciones fundamentales de la
trigonometría porque bueno la tangente
sólo es el cociente de estos verdad en
sí cuando se suman sus represas sus
representaciones polinómicas de la serie
de mclaren
son casi exactas excepto por estos
signos negativos a la representación de
la equis es decir cuando está siendo
elevado a un exponente y el número está
relacionado o al menos parece estar
relacionado íntimamente con otras cosas
excepto con la geometría verdad cierto
él lo habíamos obtenido del interés
compuesto que está relacionado con el
crecimiento exponencial o el
decrecimiento o el interés compuesto
continuo este número aparece en campos
que no están relacionados en absoluto
con la trigonometría pero sí con otros
lados de las matemáticas así que esto ya
debería hacerte pensar
y lo que es todavía más sorprendente
sería si pudiéramos de alguna manera con
esta serie series hacerlas parecer
parecidas todavía más y resulta que las
únicas diferencias son estos signos
negativos no que otra conocemos en
matemáticas que tenga un patrón parecido
a donde vamos con positivo positivo
negativo negativo y en un ciclo esencial
de 4 término si adivinas tendrás los
pelos de punta o los que ya tenían los
pelos de punta los x tendrán todavía más
el número y es decir la unidad
imaginaria porque cuáles son las
potencias de y bueno si esto no les
suena nada parecido deberían ver los
vídeos de números imaginarios otra vez
entonces cuáles serán las potencias de
iu y al acero es 1 luego y a la 1 pues
es y y al cuadrado es menos 1 y al cubo
pues es y por menos uno que es
- sí
si es menos y menos sí y luego si
multiplicamos menos y por y que sería
elevar y a la 4 sería y por 10 menos 1 y
con el menos que ya teníamos es 1 y así
la secuencia se repite a las 5 será y a
las 6 será menos 1 y a las siete será
menos y todo esto ya lo sabíamos solo es
un repaso a la octava va a ser otra vez
1 así que ya lo tenemos y esto es
sorprendente esto es sorprendente y
tiene esa propiedad por la que el
segundo término del del ciclo se vuelve
negativo pero esto no es forzosamente un
número negativo el que le sigue menos si
es el número negativo de un número
imaginario pero resulta parecido por
tanto tenemos digamos dos positivos y
dos negativos que hay bastantes cosas
interesantes que están pasando siempre
que aparece un número imaginario en
donde sale un i
qué términos corresponde pues
corresponde a los términos que vienen
del seno de x verdad corresponde a los
términos que vienen de seno de x por
ejemplo estos términos que estoy
circulando muy bien
así que tenemos algo que se parece a
algo más se parece como una especie de
secuencia de todas de todas maneras me
acabo de dar cuenta que solo tengo bueno
es que decir que normalmente soy muy
suave en estas cosas pero cuando hablo
de lo que estoy explicando ahorita la
cabeza me empieza a dar vueltas porque
esto es esto es algo que estamos a punto
de llegar es como es como la prueba de
la existencia de dios y de verdad no es
tan exagerado es la prueba definitiva de
la existencia de un orden escondido en
el universo y del que solo podemos
atisbar algo y quizás eso le podríamos
llamar dios el caso es que no me quiero
poner metafísico nos vemos luego